Good morning, John! It is Halloween and the last thing
I need is an excuse to put stuff on my head.
♫
These are funny.
I don't think they're made for men!
These aren't really men horns.
They're kind of extra fuzzy.
Maybe if I put them like this.
HrrrrRRRRRrrrrr!
Oh! Well, just like that, rest them on my glasses.
Perfect! PERFECT!
Halloween is a very Nerdfighterly day, as far as I'm concerned.
I mean, it's not like we need an excuse to, you know, be weird.
Frankly, I think that we should do it every day.
But it occurred to me recently that I wasn't really gonna be able to participate in Halloween because I'm packing
so that we can begin the Nerdfighter tour very, very soon.
So yeah, I'm not going to any Halloween parties.
We are giving out candy, but that's pretty much the extent of our Halloweeny activities.
But it did occur to me that it's quite obvious what I should be for Halloween.
And that is, of course...
Edward Spoonhands.
And if you don't know what I'm talking about, then that's just too bad.
You will soon. Like, now.
♪ Edward and Edwina Spoonhands
Have a pretty hard time of it ♪
♪ They can hardly eat cereal
And they can only type about three words a minute ♪
♪ But they both agree
It's not as bad as it could be ♪
♪ So they clack their big old fingers
And they sing a little song for you and me ♪
♫ Edward and Edwina Spoonhands
Have a pretty hard time of it ♫
♫ They can hardly eat cereal
And they can only type about three words a minute ♫
♫But they both agree
It's not as bad as it could be ♫
♫ So they clack their big old fingers
And they sing a little song for you and me ♫
♫ Edward and Edwina Spoonhands
Have a pretty hard time of it ♫
♫ They can hardly eat cereal
And they can only type about three words a minute ♫
♫But they both agree
It's not as bad as it could be ♫
♫ So they clack their big old fingers
And they sing a little song for you and me ♫
♫ Edward and Edwina Spoonhands
Have a pretty hard time of it ♫
♫ They can hardly eat cereal
And they can only type about three words a minute ♫
♫ But they both agree
It's not as bad as it could be ♫
♫ So they clack their big old fingers
And they sing a little song for you and me ♫
♫
♫ Edward and Edwina Spoonhands
Have a pretty hard time of it ♫
♫ They can hardly eat cereal
And they can only type about three words a minute ♫
♫ But they both agree
It's not as bad as it could be ♫
♫ So they clack their big old fingers
And they sing a little song for you and me ♫
♫
Nerdfighters!
Nerdfighters! John, I will see you...
I'll see you...we--I'll see you tomorrow!
Like, in the airport!
Crazy. WOOOOOO! Tour begins!
I don't know what this looks like cause I can't see anything, but to me it's kinda like Geordi LaForge.
But with horns instead of, you know,
sight vision goggles.